Nicole is in California currently we're
putting about $2,000 a month towards a
debt if we start tithing that cuts down
what we could put towards debt to about
half what do you suggest we do well the
people that asked about tithing tithing
is a tenth of your income the word tithe
in the Hebrew literally means tenth are
typically evangelical Christians or
Orthodox Jewish and those are the two
groups that tithe according to the
teachings of their book our book the
Bible and so I'm an evangelical
Christian so I tithe I give a tenth of
my income to my local church and that's
what she's asking about so where would
you put that in order of priority well
number one we start with the idea that
God doesn't need your money for that
matter the church doesn't need your
money so why does God teach us to give a
tenth of our income because it's good
for us to learn how to be givers and
generous people are just much more
attractive than selfish people and so
your baseline starting point for your
generosity for those of us that I have a
faith walk like that is a tie the tenth
of our income and so that would lead us
to believe not to make God love us more
because He loves us anyway it's not
performance-based Christianity and it's
not a thing some kind of toxic thing or
something like that where you think God
is going to give you money because you
gave him money or some kind of that not
that garbage but it is simply I'm
learning to be generous because generous
people have a better life that's really
what God's telling you to do and so he's
not going to be mad at you whichever way
you do this Nicole I'm I feel confident
that scripture teaches us to give our
tithe off the top before we do anything
else and then we just work out our plan
after that which would lead me in your
case to you know lower the amount that's
going towards the
an increase your income to a full tithe
but we're not doing that out of
performance base we're not doing it out
of a guilt trip we're certainly undoing
because of Dave Ramsey said to do it
that doesn't make any sense at all but
you're doing it out of the understanding
that your heavenly father is crazy about
you and he says hey kid when he's
looking at me
hey kid when he's looking at you you're
my son you're my daughter here's the
best way to live and if you believe all
those things about him then you would do
what he says to do because he's a great
father and so based on all of that I
tithe before I do anything else and that
will be my suggestion and the reasoning
behind my suggestion which is actually
way more important than the actual
suggestion now here's the other thing
I've discovered in 30 years of working
on these budgets with people including
my own is that there's never a zero-sum
game meaning it's never as simple as I
can put $2,000 a month towards debt if I
tithe I can put $1,000 a month towards
debt that's acting like there's only one
variable in this budget oh so you could
have a $600 car payment that you need to
sell you could be not working much and
you've got some overtime available to
you that you need to pick up you could
still have eating out in your budget to
the tune of five or six hundred bucks a
month I don't know what all is in your
budget but I do know that these aren't
the two only two variables in your
budget that you can adjust and so I'm
gonna start with the premise that my
Heavenly Father loves me he says for me
to give because it's the best way for me
to live and as an evangelical Christian
I'm gonna follow that teaching for those
reasons because it's gonna turn out best
for me because of the instruction and
the source of the instruction and then
I'm going to work on all the other
variables and I really want you to get
intense about getting out of debt so
it's not a zero-sum game there's other
stuff in your budget you can mess
here the income side of the equation the
outgo so the side of the equation and
for those of us that call ourselves
Christian especially evangelicals the
teaching is very clear on that and but
it's not a it's not a guilt-trip thing
it's not a toxic thing and it's not a
you know I talked to one financial
counselor one time years ago in another
city and he we were comparing notes and
he said he was a Christian guy he goes I
won't meet with a couple unless they
tithe and I thought man you're a serious
Pharisee
that's unbelievable I didn't say that
but that's what I thought yeah I hope I
don't care what you do is I don't care
if you worship a rock I'll help you I'm
gonna help you but you know but you
don't get to tell me what I believe I
know what I believe and but I'm gonna
help you wherever you are and if you ask
me to answer a question through the you
know through the paradigm of mathematics
or finance or academia I can answer that
question that way if you want me to
answer it through the paradigm of my
spiritual beliefs and you know I can
answer it that way yeah and oddly enough
the answer comes out the same so there
you go but sometimes I get these tweets
or this stuff on social media you know I
I really like Dave Ramsey is there a
Dave Ramsey out there - all the
religious stuff that's someone I love
you well no there's not because that's
what made a frenzy so you're not going
to find someone that has the answers
this way that don't have doesn't have
that basis for the answers it's that
simple
I mean you can get people answer your
financial questions but there's a
different there's a different vibe
around it on a different motivation
around it and so on so that's what we're
doing here